judiciaire et je vous propose de prendre
la parole madame la procureur
une enquête est actuellement en cours
des chefs de tentative d'assassinat qui
a été confiée à la direction centrale de
la police judiciaire le misanthose est
actuellement en garde à vue dans les
locaux du commissariat de police
d'Annecy le mobile reste à déterminer
des premiers éléments de l'enquête et je
vous dis vraiment sous toutes réserve
puisqu'on est sur des faits qui se sont
commis à peine 4 heures il y a aucun
mobile terroriste apparent il y a une
évaluation qui est en cours comme c'est
l'usage dans ce type de procédure par le
parquet national anti-terroriste mais en
l'état on n'a pas d'éléments qui nous
pourraient nous laisser entendre que les
motivation terroriste
l'enquête elle porte donc sur une
tentative d'assassinat nous avons six
victimes 4 mineurs et deux adultes les
quatre mineurs sont tous les quatre en
état d'urgence absolue ils ont été
transférés dans 10 heures divers
établissements hospitaliers du ressort
et en Suisse ils ont tous été victimes
de de blessures à l'arme blanche un
également victimes de d'armes blanches
plus légèrement et une sixième personne
a été victime dans un premier temps de
coup de couteau de l'auteur puis a été
au moment de l'intervention des services
de police a été blessé par une arme à
feu utilisée par les services de
pouliche précise bien que l'auteur qui
est interpellé qui était en garde à vue
n'a été trouvé porteur que d'une seule
arme qui est dans notre possession et
qui est un couteau que nous dont nous
disposons donc l'enquête se poursuit on
a été ouvert en parallèle une enquête
pour déterminer les circonstances dans
lesquelles les policiers ont fait usage
de leur armes à feu l'auteur est
actuellement garde à vue il n'est pas
blessé ou très légèrement et il va être
entendu sur ses motivations qui restent
aujourd'hui à déterminer
Madame le Procureur quel est
le parcours et le profil de du suspect 4
heures que il est l'affaire a eu lieu
c'est beaucoup trop tôt aujourd'hui pour
vous dire nous ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui
vraiment des premiers éléments c'est
qu'on est face à quelqu'un qui a priori
sans domicile fixe et qui a un parcours
migratoire en Europe avec une demande
d'Asie qui lui a été accordée pas par la
France voilà ce que je peux dire sur ce
point c'est donc en effet a priori à ce
stade il s'agit d'un syrien qui a le
statut de réfugiés en Suède depuis 10
ans qui a demandé l'asile en France mais
c'était sans objet puisqu'il a déjà le
statut de réfugiés donc c'est un
individu a priori isolé si rien avec un
statut de réfugié accordé en Suède il y
a 10 ans je précise qu'évidemment on a
pris contact avec tous les services
judiciaires et des services de
renseignement des autres pays en Europe
et au-delà et ce monsieur n'a pas
d'antécédent judiciaire n'est connu
d'aucun service de renseignement et on
n'a pas identifié d'antécédents
psychiatriques
madame borne quel est l'âge des enfants
parce qu'on parle de très jeunes enfants
quel âge les enfants et est-ce que vous
avez pu parler aux familles des témoins
je prends mes notes pour être sûr de moi
donc on a un enfant de 22 mois 2 enfants
de 2 ans et un enfant de 3 ans parmi les
quatre victimes il y en a un qui est
nationalité néerlandaise et incinération
a été anglaise c'était des touristes
puisque les faits ont lieu sur une aire
de jeux qui se trouve sur un parc face
au lac d'Annecy donc ils sont tous les
victimes sont prises en charge les
autorités consulaires sont au courant il
y avait un certain nombre de victimes
visuelles donc qui ne sont pas qui n'ont
pas été blessés par les larmes blanches
mais qui ont été témoins et qui sont
extrêmement choqués puisque c'est sur un
jardin public très fréquenté notamment
il y avait une classe de lycéens qui
actuellement prise en charge par une
cellule médico-psychologique et avec une
prise en charge par l'association d'aide
aux victimes endatés par le parquet
est-ce que je peux dire c'est que ce
sont des tout petits enfants qui ont été
blessés vraiment très grièvement je
pense que quand en tant que parents et
en tant que citoyen on imagine on est
déjà très choqués on a pu échanger avec
ceux qui sont intervenus pour sauver ses
enfants je faisais que c'est très très
choquant et c'est vraiment une énorme
émotion de tous ceux qui ont pu
intervenir et qui sont intervenus dans
les meilleurs délais pour assurer la
prise en charge de ces petits victimes
madame la Première ministre au-delà de
la tristesse il a peut-être de la colère
est-ce que vous comprenez ceux qui
s'interrogent y compris dans la classe
politique sur le parcours migratoire
effectivement de cette personne et donc
sur la politique migratoire menée alors
je le redis c'est une personne qui a un
statut de réfugiés en Suède donc il
circule au sein de l'Union européenne et
je pense qu'avant de s'emballer sur des
conclusions sur ces sujets il faut
attendre que l'enquête puisse avoir lieu
je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est le temps
de l'émotion ça doit être le temps de
l'unité de solidarité avec ces petits
enfants avec leurs parents avec leur
famille et avec tous les habitants
d'Annecy qui sont évidemment choqués
parce qu'il s'est passé
bienvenue vous venez de suivre justement
cette ce point presse de la première
ministre Elisabeth borne ainsi que de la
procureur de la République pour faire un
peu plus la lumière même si il ne s'est
pas dit grand-chose dans ce drame qui
s'est déroulé ce matin à Annecy je suis
avec Jean-Marc Leclerc je reste au
service société bonjour Jean-Marc merci
d'être avec nous vous allez nous
éclairer nos décrypter un peu ce qui
s'est ce qui s'est passé déjà vous
rappelez il fait que s'il est passé ce
matin à Annecy
tragique c'est un individu isolé qui
subitement il ressemble à une espèce de
coup de folie dans un parc sans prend à
de tout jeunes enfants à des adultes
aussi qui finit par être
écarté par quelques adultes de courageux
qu'on voit d'ailleurs dans les images
qui ont été diffusées et qui finit par
être enfin interpellé par des policiers
qui étaient qui étaient présents dans le
secteur et qui en a fini par interpeller
et donc il est tombé
alors avant de parler de station le
bilan la famille et la popular l'ont
appelée 4 mineurs deux adultes 4 mineurs
les quatre avec le process vital engagé
oui évidemment ça se passe ça se passe
extrêmement rapidement des petits corps
fragiles l'enfant de 22 mois je sais pas
si vous imaginez l'horreur de la
situation
voilà je pense que tous les Français qui
ont vu ou qui verront ces images par les
réseaux sociaux notamment notamment les
images les plus crues les plus proches
de la réalité de la scène criminelle et
bien seront absolument horrifiés par
à la fois la froide détermination du de
l'agresseur présumée puisque c'est comme
ça qu'il faut le qualifier tant qu'il
n'est pas confondu définitivement et
puis
et puis voilà et donc un sentiment
d'impuissance
d'inéluctabilité même presque je dirais
parce que qui peut imaginer que une
scène de cette nature se passe dans un
parc d'enfants dans un endroit aussi
idyllique d'ailleurs que ce bordel parc
d'Annecy effectivement dans ce cadre
c'est attaillant qu'est-ce qu'on sait de
lui aujourd'hui
alors on sait que c'est d'abord c'est
quelqu'un de nationalité étrangère
c'est un Syrien il est né en Syrie il a
31 ans
il est né en octobre 91 si manoir est
bonne et il a donc vécu
cette installer en Suède en 2013
il a demandé l'asile alors il y a encore
un petit doute sur l'année précise où il
a obtenu l'asile en Suède parce qu'on a
entendu des choses des versions un peu
différentes elle sera un point à
éclaircir le fait est qu'en fait après
avoir été en Suède déposé sa demande
d'asile où il a fondé une famille il
avait une femme et apparemment un enfant
qui est aujourd'hui âgé de 3 ans il a
déposé une nouvelle demande d'Asie cette
fois-ci en France
sachant que en tant que demandeur
d'asile ou même en tant que réfugié
avéré plus tard puisque l'asile lui a
été attribué par la Suède et bien quoi
qu'il en soit il pouvait circuler si
librement dans l'espace Schengen et donc
par contre la curiosité c'est que c'est
qu'il a déposé une deuxième demande en
France ce qui est
le principe c'est que c'est le pays de
première entrée qui s'occupe de la
demande d'asile c'est les fameux accords
de Dublin et donc là il y a une
étrangeté dans son parcours qu'il
faudrait éclairer pour savoir si on a
été négligeant dans la détection
peut-être de de son statuter Laurent
Wauquiez qui est en train qui est en
train de parler et on reviendrait après
et je pense que personne peut imaginer
ça personne peut imaginer la barbarie
l'ampleur de la violence de ce qui s'est
passé
quand on est parents et il y avait une
maman qui était là on voyait dans ses
yeux elle avait juste son fils qui était
juste devant elle et qui a réussi à
échapper je pense que l'ampleur du choc
est énorme pour tout le monde
et il y a aussi de la colère bien sûr
qu'il y a ça
de se dire mais comment c'est possible
quand c'est possible un jardin d'enfance
précipitait il y a un enfant de 22 mois
au moment où on parle qui lutte pour la
vie
un enfant de 22 mois qui lutte pour la
vie c'est ce que je viens de dire
Laurent Wauquiez justement on ne peut
personne ne peut imaginer de l'avoir
varie il y a de la colère on en parlait
de du statut de réfugiés est-ce que
quelque chose aurait pu être fait c'est
ce que je demande aujourd'hui la classe
politique
l'élément troublant dans dans ce
parcours tel que on est dans les
premières heures on attaque il semble se
dessiner c'est que on peut se demander
comment
ce ce syrien
a pu déposer une demande d'asile en
France
sans que
il y a une réaction immédiate
[Musique]
voilà on sent qu'il y a un embarras
quand même autour de cette question là
ça va être ça va être délayé
tranquillement et et on y verra plus
clair pour savoir s'il y a eu
effectivement des failles ou pas pour
l'instant c'est vrai que c'est la
période instant de l'émotion de la
concorde nationale de tout ça évidemment
parce que c'est c'est une affaire très
marquante au plan criminel et donc voilà
mais il y aura des explications sans
doute plus technique plus politique dans
un second temps oui effectivement on a
on a entendu d'ailleurs la classe
politique dès ce matin une minute de
silence qui a eu lieu d'ailleurs à
l'Assemblée nationale il y a aussi une
question qui a été posée forcément très
rapidement c'est est-ce qu'il y a un
mobile théoriste et là la procureur a
répondu elle a dit aucun mobile
théorique à part au moment où on se
parle là le parquet antiterroriste un
procède à ce qu'on appelle une
évaluation de la situation pour voir si
ça remplit les critères habituels du
terrorisme là en l'occurrence c'est vrai
que il y a des éléments assez troublants
comme le fait par exemple que ce
monsieur aura dépend des une demande
d'asile en tant que chrétien il aurait
paraît-il été interpellé ce sera vérifié
avec d'ailleurs une croix
autour du cou c'est vrai que il y a en
Syrie il y a pas que des musulmans il y
a aussi des chrétiens beaucoup
d'ailleurs sont arrivés en Suède dans
les premières vagues puisque ça fait un
moment qu'il est arrivé
de Syrie en Suède il est arrivé en 2013
donc alors ce petit que effectivement il
soit arrivé dans une vague de chrétiens
qu'on a accepté c'est possible il faudra
le vérifier à moins que ce soit une
fausse information voilà ça ça va être
clarifié assez rapidement je pense et
puis donc évidemment au moment où on se
parle le parquet en terroriste se dit un
chrétien syrien qui vient poignarder des
enfants dans un parc sans apparemment
crier
des slogans religieux du à lakbar ou
comme c'est fréquemment le cas comme ça
avait été le cas par exemple à Marseille
souvenez-vous en 2017 c'est de jeunes
femmes poignardées
bon là c'était quand même assez
manifeste bon là on a des éléments qui
laissent à penser que quand même c'est
un périple individuel étrange voilà
alors il va y avoir des perquisitions
sans doute menées auprès de ses proches
en tout cas et puis des informations qui
viendront aussi de Suède on va on va
voir s'éclairer un peu le parcours les
fréquentations de ce monsieur et on
verra si le mobile terroriste c'est
clair ou non oui oui parce que comme le
disait la poker on est quatre heures
après l'effet
c'est encore très tôt il y a pas
d'éléments immédiat qui laisse à penser
ou qu'il donne des éléments douteux sur
la possibilité que ce soit terroriste
oui et une nouvelle fois on aura
probablement d'ailleurs une nouvelle
conférence de presse de la procureur
dans les jours à venir on imagine
Jean-Marc oui oui c'est parce que voilà
il y a beaucoup de questions encore
posées ça va ça va se décanter
progressivement il faut laisser la
justice le temps de vérifier point par
point les choses les enquêteurs de la
police judiciaire d'Annecy qui sont sur
ce travail sont pas des débutants ils
ont travaillé sur des affaires
importantes autrefois ce sont des gens
compétent
voilà donc on verra après comment ça va
comment ça va évoluer mais la police
judiciaire fait son travail pour
l'instant et voilà faut leur laisser le
temps de dérouler la pelote
tranquillement très bien merci beaucoup
Jean-Marc d'avoir été avec nous on
pourra lire d'ailleurs votre article à
retrouver demain sur le figurant même ce
soir sur le site internet merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous et merci à vous
les internautes d'avoir été nombreux à
nous suivre vous pouvez suivre bien
évidemment toute cette enfin toutes les
dernières informations que nous avons
sur ce drame sur le site du Figaro nous
avons ouvert un direct et dès que nous
avons d'autres informations nous voulons
partagerons dessus merci à vous et à
bientôt sur figarolive